we have a voicemail number and that
number is two one nine two david p let's
take a listen to what this caller said
it was up david a my question is this to
get the arms the moral code for get the
possibility of trump being impeached
let's say none of those stuff happened
in 2020 when he runs and lose the last
two month or two months what do you
think he would do obviously he a fair
election was rigged and all that's
though but when he try to hang on to
power he burn the place down
exist give me some other possibilities
all right thanks i'm by late islamic fee
brown i must be brown from compton
alright so the question is would ace a
lame-duck trump be dangerous whether
it's because he loses in 2020 or wins in
2020 and then gets to the end of his
presidency in 2024 what is what a lame
duck trumpet be dangerous number one
when Obama was president you had the
right wing conspiracy theorist saying
trump that Obama rather was going to
declare martial law and prevent there
being a 2016 election to remain in power
indefinitely of course there was no
indication that that Obama was going to
do that
he never even implied he was going to do
that contrary to that Donald Trump did
actually say a few months ago that he
was impressed by the Chinese President
ending term limits and potentially
staying in power indefinitely and that
maybe it's something that we would try
here in the United States someday so
based solely on what Obama versus Trump
said if you thought Obama maybe was
gonna cancel future elections Trump
actually said he might want to end term
limits yeah I mean I don't think Trump
would declare martial law or anything
like that but he did lose in a
reelection bid he would certainly go
down kicking and screaming he would not
be very happy with that a more realistic
concern short of he's gonna cancel
elections or declare martial law is that
if you thought Trump was unabashedly
doing corrupt and crony istic stuff in
the first year of his presidency just
you wait until he's in the last two
months of what he knows will be the end
of his presidency it would be a level of
crony capitalist corruption and nepotism
and just disgusting vile swamp filling
the likes of which we maybe have never
seen
before I think there's a good chance
that he won't even run for re-election I
mean by the time that comes around he
may say hey I'm 73 74 years old you
think I served that one-term I made
America great again and I'm cashing out
Mike Pence can take the lead it would be
an example of him doing his own thing
it's not that common for presidents not
to run for re-election we know that he
has already filed for reelection and of
course that might have been a campaign
maneuver in order to continue raising
money which he has been doing but maybe
he will ultimately say I've accomplished
everything we made America great again
and now I'm gonna leave I don't know the
answer to that but I would be very very
worried about an unabashed shameless
lame-duck Trump whether it happens in
2020 or whether it happens in 2024 on
the bonus show today we're gonna go over
yesterday's primary election results
there were a few primaries three
primaries yesterday that were very very
interesting the results may be tell us
about what we can expect in the midterms
we'll talk about Google's latest AI
booking a hair appointment over the
phone and nobody realized the
receptionist didn't realize that they
were not speaking to a real human and
people freaked out and I will also talk
about Gina hospital's confirmation
hearings earlier today to be confirmed
to CIA director that is all happening on
today's bonus show thanks for watching
we will speak to you then